that is weird
Hey t-series has most likely patched me
so it doesn't matter what I upload at
this point there's it I mean I might as
well get this over with book review -
turtle smush like if you're excited yeah
let's get some hype in the chat guys as
always I've been reading I've been doing
my homework
have you I've been reading a lot of
great literature book of disquiet
amazing loved it how is it the dead
Lolita
loved it I'm not gonna kiss it though
The Count of Monte Cristo whoa for some
reason I thought I would see through
myself that's the level of brain let I
am incredible it recommended by its law
so I hmm
definitely a kiss from pukes I also read
these two books which we're gonna
discuss today Oh God
can't show that it's got titties on the
front now let's just jump into it shall
we
I told you guys to read this book did
you do your homework I'm sorry I made
you guys read this and then six months
later Here I am okay but you read it you
have plenty of time to finish this come
on
literally you could pause the video and
finish it now do it let's review this
together for the first time of book
review so little quickly about Kobo
Abbey he is described as the Franz Kafka
of Japan whatever that means I'm told
that he focuses on nightmarish type of
scenario which definitely fits into this
novel I picked this book because it's
very simple read and I know that you
guys are simpletons I'm just kidding I
just wanted something that everyone can
enjoy it's also sort of deceivingly
straightforward in the sense that
there's a hidden meaning in there you
got to read between the lines boys first
of all let's go through the synopsis
there's actually a film based on this
movie which one it says here in the back
a won the 1973 Cannes Film Festival and
it's an amazing family I definitely
recommend you guys should watch it so
the story starts off with a man walking
on the dunes we don't really know
anything about him however the book
itself starts off where
telling us about a man who disappeared
and no one saw and after seven years
there was no trace of him so therefore
the police declare him as dead so we
follow this man who walks in the dunes
we don't really know anything about him
like I said except that he likes to
collect insects as a hobby and that's
why he's on this far away sand dunes to
hopefully find rare species of insects
he takes a nap and when he wakes up he
finds out that he missed the last bus
from to return him to wherever he lives
and therefore he meets up with some of
the locals who are first that he can
stay with them overnight so the locals
basically live in these houses that are
located within the dunes so they are
deep down between these giant mall
substan dissention so you'd have to
climb down through a rope ladder to get
down to one of the houses now at first
everything seems fine who mets up with a
woman who lives there and he's gonna
stay just overnight with her
however we are told very quickly that
something is off about this whole
situation
not just from her face god damn that's
creepy could I take a bath first yes but
you should do it after tomorrow
next day he finds out that the ladder is
gone so he can't leave the place he
tries to climb by but it's basically
impossible since the sand is so coarse
and it just gets everywhere so to
prevent the house from getting crushed
by the constant flow of sand they have
to shovel sand aside away from the house
and that's just a constant thing they
have to do and the woman therefore wants
him to stay with him to help him do this
labor that they are obligated to do to
live in this very bizarre location
there's one way to describe this book is
if you don't like saying I got bad news
for you I love that I love the comments
and this I had to drink a lot of water
during watching this movie hit yet again
George Lucas steal from another film I
can't believe it I don't
George Lucas stole from us yet again so
this is the basic plot he tries to do
everything he can to escape from this
situation he's also quite clever which
is nice for a change when people are
stuck in these weird situation he also
even managed to escape at one point but
he gets caught because it's just too far
off this place and he gets taken back to
the house again
[Music]
at the end of the novel he had even
discovered a way to exert water from the
sand so he could get drinking water much
more easily which is obviously a big
discovery for him but that doesn't
really help him escape from the place
either and the last page basically reads
spoilers there was no particular need to
hurry about escaping on the two-way
ticket he held in his hand now the
destination and time of departure were
blanks for him to fill in as he wished
in addition he realized that he was
bursting with a desire to talk to
someone about the water trance and if he
wanted to talk about it
there wouldn't be better listeners than
the villagers he would end by telling
someone if not today then tomorrow he
might as well put off his escape until
sometime after that and he was therefore
declared a missing person
so Kobo Abbott himself lived very poor
at some point in his life I don't know
when but he lived with his wife and he
basically sustained himself from selling
vegetables and charcoal I think he must
have drawn from that personal experience
into this story very similarly in this
novel the main character still has the
bare minimum to get by he still gets
food he still gets cigarettes he still
occasionally gets suck and if he saves
up money the people in the village he
can trade stuff with these all
essentials is also at the cost of his
freedom of course and by the end of the
novel we know that he has already made
his choice and he chose to stay which
means he doesn't just lose his freedom
but he also essentially disappears just
like in the beginning of the novel I
know that which happened to another
person now the sign in this novel is
what prisons the main character it's
what keeps him trapped in and forced to
do this physical labor to stay alive and
just like time the sand is constantly
flowing it's something that he can't
escape from if he doesn't stop it will
literally crush him
I guess he begs the question what's the
difference of being trapped by time
and being trapped by the signs like this
character even if you escape are you
ever really truly free
aren't we all trapped in one way or
another but I really think that is
probably what I mean I don't know you
can obviously interpret as many waves
but it's like he discovered this trap at
the end being to get water more easily
and it's a way for him to distract
himself from this idea of escape when in
reality does it even matter clearly he
doesn't see the carrot the main
character anymore it kind of reminded me
actually a little bit about those sodium
skis House of the Dead
because Dostoevsky the writer he went to
prison himself in Siberia and he I
remember there was a line that I
remember it said man's greatest ability
is to be accustomed to anything I think
that was something like that and it
seemed to me like Kobe wanted to ask the
question if you have the bare minimum to
get by would you be satisfied with it
would that be enough for you I would
look forward to read what you guys
thought about this novel if you read it
let me know in the comments down below I
really recommend reading it even if you
heard me spoil at it cuz it is a really
fun nice read I mean come on
it even has pictures in it what more can
you ask for darn amazing I would give
this a four out of five a really nice
book let's move on next vote
Kierkegaard's
why has no one told me about care
command I'm kind of annoyed as a scandi
bro you'd think they would teach us in
school about one of the greatest
philosophers the father of extensionism
everyone Suren character guard denmark
you know what a possible rectangle you
did something that much turkey God
focused on the subject of what it meant
to be existing what it meant to be a
human basically it was also a Christian
which really annoys me which we'll get
into eventually but he's all the very
interesting guy I read up a little bit
about him he his father stood on top of
a mountain and cursed God for his
misfortunes and then shortly after he
was became very successful in textile
business selling sweaters I don't know
so Saren himself he grew up very rich
his father was very strict on him and he
noticed how intelligent Stern was at the
very young age so he instructed Saren to
always become third at everything in
class he was not to stand out from any
of it his other students obviously he
obeyed his dad and so he did and I think
that's a really interesting testimony to
his genius not just become first but
actually managed to come through it
third every time he also dressed very
strangely pump schewe soar very dressed
up for his age and a lot of people would
call him baby man or something like that
young old man maybe because he'd also
have a back injury so he would always be
hunched over a little bit and I think
that's actually how he passed away from
very painfully poor siren oh well so I
picked up either/or because that's one
of his first greater works and it's
genius I absolutely loved it I think
well maybe not everything will get into
that the book starts out very
confusingly as a narrator or someone
explaining that they found these texts
kind of like found-footage horror game
look I just stumbled upon these guys
it's totally real and the person who
found these texts found them inside a
bureau and he by just pure chance he
concluded that they were written by two
different people which he named
it's a and B and these are the two
different people that Cherokee God
categorizes a is the esthetic and B is
the ethic so he does is very cleverly as
a way to kind of distance himself from
what his own ideas actually are but
knowing character God's life and and
learning about it it's pretty obvious
that he's gone through both of these
stages so you're supposed to be able to
read it in whatever order you want so
you can read you can read B first and
you can read a after but I would
definitely read it a and B I think at
least it doesn't matter I tried reading
this in Danish first but it was just too
hard and I couldn't do it I think that
I'll lose more on trying to understand
Danish than just what is lost on the
translation but I was actually excited
about reading potentially and maybe it
was Norwegian I could do it so it starts
up with a which is the aesthetic point
of view and boy oh boy it started off so
interesting with the really thoughtful
existential ideas and then out of
nowhere he just hits you with 200 pages
on the Don Giovanni opera that's right
everyone 200 dense pages describing why
the Don Giovanni opera is the greatest
thing ever
I'm convinced that no one has actually
read this book because goddamn that was
tough to get through I am really glad I
did though
I think obviously reading this kind of
philosophy a lot of it is lost on me
it's not like I take notes or anything
while I read it I wish I did though I am
actually happy though how much more
susceptible I am to this kind of
literature as opposed to last year when
I try to read Nietzsche and it was just
it felt like one big blur so the
aesthetic get on with it feelings the
aesthetic focuses on your own pleasures
and experiences and as an aesthetic you
seek to maximize these experiences and
pleasures that is the goal of the
aesthetic it's very egotistical almost
you could say so to summarize these 200
pages the opera makes me feel good
basically now learning about a character
God he himself lived as an aesthetic in
his younger years when his father passed
away I think he probably felt very
liberate
in a sense just from hearing how strict
his dad was towards Aaron he obviously
inherited his money as well so he got
financial freedom as well to really just
live this aesthetic lifestyle he would
get drunk very often and these sort of
thing now being aesthetic or living the
aesthetic lifestyle obviously has it
advantageous it distracts us from any
anxiety it instructs us from boredom and
Kierkegaard put great emphasis on
boredom it's not just that you're bored
if you are bored then you're not
stimulated properly which means you are
psychologically not healthy so the
aesthetic life point is just a way to
escape this boredom and however
Kierkegaard points out that eventually
I'm not sure I'm pronouncing aesthetic
correct by the way but the inevitable
problem with it is that due to
repetition we will eventually inevitably
get bored
whatever temporary relief we have from
watching another PewDiePie video will
eventually fade due to repetition I know
it sucks okay but that's the truth only
when experiencing something for the
first time is when we truly appreciate
something and/or not only but mostly and
also based on how we think how often we
can experience something maybe if you go
on a trip you will appreciate that trip
more if you know you you can only get go
there once the transformation or the
move from the aesthetic point of view to
the ethic point of view which is
something character God went through
himself which had a big impact on not
just his life but his philosophy was
when Kierkegaard was going to marry
Regina Olsen so he was engaged to Regina
Olsen but he decided to call off the
wedding because he wanted to focus on
his philosophy for him to break up this
engagement had a huge took a huge toll
on character guard because socially he
got rejected obviously a lot of people
were angry at him for making this
decision and I can just imagine what
that would mean to go through with the
choice like that not just losing your
life but also these other consequences
that follows it but I can imagine that
in his mind his love for Regina
would be kept the strongest by also
calling off the wedding
he writes here the famous line in the
book is there either or an aesthetic
lecture if you marry you will regret it
if you do not marry you will also regret
it if you marry or if you do not marry
you will regret both whether you marry
or you do not marry you will regret both
whether you laugh at the world's Foley's
or you weep over them
you will regret both believe a girl you
will regret it if you do not believe her
you will also regret it if you believe a
girl or you do not believe her you will
regretful whether you believe a girl or
you do not believe her you will regret
both if you hang yourself you will
regret it if you do not hang yourself
you will regret it if you hang yourself
or you do not hang yourself you will
regret both whether you hang yourself or
you do not hang yourself you will regret
both this gentleman is the sum of all
practical wisdom okay now this is
obviously a very famous line to be fair
don't read this expecting that it's just
going to be like that nevertheless
character guards transformation into the
ethic point of view I think at least I
don't know the ethic point of view is
for living for the greater good for the
greater good of society and living
beyond your own needs he also points out
through the character be that choices in
his life have led him through different
paths some that were obviously very hard
for him character got himself made many
choices in his life that are kind of
questionable but he acknowledged that it
was his choices nonetheless and he
emphasized that on the ethical point of
view and that you must take
responsibility for your choices which he
definitely did yeah I think he also I
don't remember exactly but he had some
quarrel with the church just because of
another really strange decision sorry I
know that's a big I just don't remember
Cherokee odd then brings up that problem
with the ethical point of view which is
despair which he defines as the tension
between the finite and infinite as a
human you're scared of dying but you are
also probably don't want to live forever
either he says that we can never really
escape this anxiety or boredom or
despair unless that's right thank you
character guard there is a solution to
your
problem that you brought up with a sec
essentialism thank you so much character
and I appreciate it what is it oh you
must take a leap of faith in God
thanks character guard very cool that's
right everybody all you have to do is
believe in God no matter what character
God says that God is always right no
matter what and you should take a leap
of faith in believing in him even if
there is not a single evidence for it
and that's how we adopt a religious
stage of life and we escape the boredom
we escape the anxiety and we escape the
despair I did a big mistake I think of
reading these two at the same time don't
do that just don't do that very bad idea
I genuinely felt terrible while reading
those these I didn't think what I read
would affect me so much but it did and I
would not recommend it I'm glad I read
them however but I'm also glad it's over
that's it's for book review hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did smash
like subscribe we can bring back and
stop tea series again let's do it I'm
gonna post what the next book review is
on the subreddit book Clapp review clamp
so if you're interesting and following
well on the next book review in the book
club check out the link in description I
think you guys can really enjoy it
reading it's definitely made my life
something and that's it bye
what to purse emulators becoming
relevant
no no don't leave no please
sponsor eagle please do something yes
this game is still relevant god dammit